- Liam Neesons is my shiznit!
- Woo!
- But, you know who I
like as much as Neesons?
- (blows raspberry)
As much as Neesons?
- Mm-hmm.
- Who?
- Bruce Willy.
(valet attendant screams)
(feet tapping rhythmically)
(valet attendant
continues screaming)
- Bruce Willy is my (beep)!
(upbeat music)
So, it's definitely happening?
We're makin' a record?
(chuckles) No, I promise,
it's gonna be a hit.
Hey, no, man, thank you.
- What's up, my man?
I heard about your
record deal, dog.
You gonna keep it
real, now, right?
Right, you gonna stay
true to your roots, right?
You ain't gonna let down
your boy, your boy, Dwayne?
- Dwayne Washington.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Ramsey Junior High.
(car horn honks)
- Yo, yo, yo!
If it ain't Craig, the
man of the hour, homie.
- Uh-huh.
- You remember me,
I'm Theresa cousin.
You gonna keep it real?
- Yeah, I'm definitely
gonna keep it real, man.
So, yeah.
(garbage rustles)
- What up, what up?
It's my favorite Craig.
- Mm-hmm.
- I don't know you, man.
- You don't know me?
(beep) Is that how
it's gonna be, Craig?
- No, I really don't know you.
- You changed.
- All right, you good,
(phone ringing)
you good, you can stay.
- Craig's phone.
- Hey, young blood.
(crowd growing loud
with chatter) My girls
take care of you,
you take care of me.
(crowd growing
loud with chatter)
- Oh, all right, all right.
(crowd continuously grows
louder with chatter)
(upbeat music)
Oh!
(crowd chattering loudly)
All right.
(crowd continues
chattering loudly)
(phone ringing)
- Hello, Craig's phone.
It's for you, brother.
- Oh, thanks, man, thanks.
All right, hello?
(crowd shushing loudly)
Yeah.
It fell through?
(crowd growing quiet)
It's not happening?
(Craig sighs)
Damn, man.
(sighs) Nah, it's all right.
Thanks anyway.
Sorry, everybody...
(wind whooshing loudly)
(trash bag clatters)
(train whistles)
Damn.
(wind continues whooshing)
(dramatic music)
(sirens distantly blaring)
(gun hammer clicks)
- What, what, what, what, what?
- Check yourself, before I
body pierce your damn skull.
- Think you can
pull that trigger
before I blow your personality
out the back of your head?
Then, go right ahead
and test the hypothesis
and see what happens.
- All right, I'm gonna give you
a straight-up vampire
C-section, like we was,
- [Both] Edward and Bella.
(dramatic music continues)
- Hold up.
You like Twilight?
- Yeah, I like Twilight, (beep)!
- (beep) Twilight's my jam.
- You an Edward (beep)
or a Jacob (beep)?
- Answer that (beep) together.
Three, two, one.
- [Both] Edward.
(both exhaling in disbelief)
- Oh, sh-yeah.
- Yeah.
- Are you (beep) with me?
- You're either playin'
some (beep) up game,
or you went straight
up inside my head.
- Yo, and when you said you
was gonna blow my personality
out the back of my head,
I'm like, "That sounds like
some (beep) I would say."
Psh, and now, this
Twilight (beep)?
- It's wavelength, (beep).
- So, I guess we friends, then?
- Oh, we best friends, now!
We the best of friends!
- BFFs?
- We are BFFs, MF.
(upbeat music)
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ The whole world
stops turnin' around ♪
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ Both feet are off the ground ♪
♪ Trumpets start to sound ♪
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ It's Heaven when
you're around ♪
♪ La, la, la, la ♪
(Jordan laughing)
- No, you didn't.
No, you did not. (laughs)
This some crazy, that's
the craziest story, man.
(both laughing wheezily)
Ooh, it's too much, boy.
(soft piano music)
(Jordan coughing)
(Jordan wheezing)
(Jordan exhales loudly)
(soft piano music continues)
(Michael grunts softly)
Team Edward.
(soft piano music continues)
(car humming)
(police siren whirs)
(birds chirping)
(car door thuds shut)
(footsteps thudding softly)
- Mm, mm, mm, yeah.
Looks like another
gang-related killing.
- (laughs) Surprise,
sur-mother-(beep)-prise.
(officer continues laughing)
- Yo, yo, yo, what
up, what up, what up,
welcome to Battle Rap, you hear?
We're gonna battle rap every day
in the month of February, y'all.
Yo, I'm your host, Big P. Peru.
- [Crowd] Peru!
- That's right, that's right,
that's right, that's right.
To my left, we got the champion.
Yo, introduce, son.
- Yeah, what's happenin'?
This your boy, Rhino D.,
and I'm about to front-hand,
(Rhino D.'s arm whooshes)
backhand his ass up in here.
(crowd cheering)
- That's right, that's
right, that's right.
On my right, we
got the challenger.
Introduce yourself, boy.
- Yeah, what's up, man, I'm
Dylan Killin' in the house,
100 USDA pure meat,
- Ah!
- No filler, right here, dawg.
- Ha ha!
- Yeah!
- Okay, okay, okay, yo,
Dylan lost the toss,
so you go first.
Okay, gentleman, battle rap.
♪ Yeah, all right,
yeah, man, here we go ♪
♪ You're shook, son ♪
♪ I'ma eat you for breakfast ♪
- What, ha ha!
♪ 'Cause I'm a crook, son ♪
♪ I stole a cop-a-feel from
your girl's breasts-es ♪
(crowd exclaiming)
(friend exclaiming loudly)
- That ain't nothin', man.
(friend continues
exclaiming loudly)
♪ You don't even know, man ♪
♪ Hey, listen, man, you can't
even win this 100-yard dash ♪
(friend continues exclaiming)
♪ But let me ask
you a question ♪
♪ What do they call
that, a mustache ♪
(crowd exclaiming)
(friend continues exclaiming)
- Relax, man.
I'm askin', relax, man.
(friend exclaiming rowdily)
Hey, I need to you
relax a little bit.
(friend grows louder
in exclamation)
I need you to take
it down a little bit.
(friend continues exclaiming)
What the (beep) are you doin'?
Can you take it down
a little bit, man?
(friend continues exclaiming)
(friend stomps feet)
Come on, what are you, a horse?
(friend cries out)
(friend stomps feet)
That's the last one.
♪ Yo, what's up, dog ♪
♪ You know my (beep) is rich ♪
♪ I'm swimmin' in simoleons ♪
♪ I mean, what am
I supposed to do ♪
♪ With this miniature
black Napoleon ♪
(crowd exclaiming)
(friend cries out)
(friend exclaiming rowdily)
- Hey, man. Hey, yo, get
your- (friend crying out)
Hey, hey!
(friend continues crying out)
Hey, I will walk out.
I will walk out.
Hey, hey.
(friend shrieks)
- Just hang back for a second.
(keys jingling)
Look it, look at this,
(friend growling)
look at that, look at that,
look at that. Oh, oh, yeah,
(friend continues growling)
look at it, go get it, man,
go get it! That's a boy.
♪ Yeah, man, here we go, man ♪
♪ Man, look at the chain ♪
♪ And your stanky
ass Timberlands ♪
(friend cries out) ♪
(crowd exclaiming)
(friend continues exclaiming)
(crowd chattering in confusion)
- Hey, hey, no, no,
no, no, hey, hey.
(friend continues exclaiming)
I don't know what...
Why are you doin' me?
(friend continues exclaiming)
Why would you, no, listen.
(friend shrieks)
No, no, no, no, no, come on.
(friend continues shrieking)
Here we go, shh, shh, shh, shh.
Shh, shh, shh, shh.
- All right, you gotta go, man.
- Oh, no, no.
(crowd exclaiming)
- No, you're out, you're
out, you're done, man.
(friend continues exclaiming)
That's right, man.
Yo, we got a champion, still,
we got a champion, still.
(crowd cheering)
- Yeah, I was hittin' it.
Yeah, that's what I'm talkin-
(friend shrieking loudly)
- Give me the hat!
(Dylan calling after
shrieking friend)
No, you're hittin',
give the (beep) hat!
(upbeat heroic music)
- Lando, what?
Oh, snap, yo, Lando!
Yo, Lando Calrissian.
- Oh, hi, yeah, that's me.
- Dude, Lando!
Yo, yo, you straight up runnin'
Cloud City right now, dog!
(Lando chuckles lightly)
That's you, man!
You out there, just, (mimics
spaceship firing bullets).
Swoosh!
- Well, you know, I do my best.
- Zeef, man.
Zeef Howdo, big fan, big fan.
- Well, Zeef,
- Nice to meet you.
- It's real nice to
make your acquaintance.
- Straight up, dog,
straight up, man,
you an inspiration
to all of us, man.
You the reason I'm out
here in Cloud City, dog.
Man, I ain't jokin', man.
- That's nice.
- But, yo, ideally, though,
- Yeah?
- Ideally, on an
ideal situation,
I would be doin',
like, what you doin'.
I'd be up there in,
like, the high chambers
of Cloud City, dog.
- Well, Zeef, it's
nice to meet you.
- Yo, right on, man,
'cause they got me
in the carbonite
room right now, son.
That's bull (beep), right?
They got me workin' with
some pig dudes and whatnot.
Yo, I ain't no pig, you know?
Have you ever noticed, man,
there ain't a lot of
brothers out here,
man, in space, right?
It's like they tryin'
to keep us down, man.
- Well, you know what, I don't
think that it's a policy,
I just think it's
really, really difficult
to get to this level.
You've gotta understand
the politics of the empire,
and, at the same time,
all the motivations
of the rebel alliance.
- All that, man,
all that, all that,
- You've got-
- All that, all that,
all that, all that, but
ideally, though, man,
ideally, what I'm talkin'
about is, like, me and you,
we should, like, do somethin'
together, though, man.
(Lando exhales loudly) 'Cause,
if you think about it, yo,
when I was younger, man,
I used to fly those
land-speeders all the time,
my friends was like, "Man,
you should be piloting
"one of the X-wings, right?"
(door whirs open) And, so
that's like disappointing, man,
'cause I got here, and
they just had me, like,
cleanin' up the R2 units
after the X-wings come in.
- Zeef, I gotta go.
(door whirs shut)
You should probably,
(door whirs open)
- Oh, man, I'm sayin', man,
how do we contact one another?
'Cause that's the
most important thing,
that we contact one another.
(door whirs shut)
'Cause, yo, look, man,
(door whirs open)
ideally, though,
ideally, though, I would
get to fly, somehow,
like, the Millennium Falcon,
like, that would be cool,
and yo, let me get you
my, like, my contact,
(door whirs shut)
I got my card
in here somewhere.
(device beeps)
Man, I'm just tryin' to find
this in my pocket, right here.
(door whirs open)
Sometimes these suits,
they don't have no pockets.
- Well, you know what, Zeef,
just give your information
to Lobot, here,
and we'll be in touch.
- Lobot?
Man, I see how it is.
I gotta talk to your
man-droid right now?
Man, (beep) you, (beep),
little white ass hair.
Why you wearin' a
cape, though, huh?
Where you goin', the
ice planet, Hoth?
- Outrageous.
(triumphant music)
- Thank you, and may
God bless America.
(audience applauding)
- All right, just a
couple introductions,
and we'll get you outta here.
This is John O'Rourke.
- Nice to meet you, John.
- Mr. Ian Roberts.
- Nice to meet you.
- Pierre Ortencio.
- All right, nice to meet you.
- Jerome Smith.
- Come on, bro.
What's up, fam? (laughs)
You know this.
- Heath Williams, sir.
- Nice to meet you.
- Mary Woodbury.
- Jay Martel.
- Nice to meet you, sir.
- Tasha Robins.
- Come on, come on, come on.
(Tasha laughs)
(President humming)
(inhales loudly) Feel that?
- Emily George.
- All right,
nice to meet you.
- Daryl Stokes.
- Come on, what's up, fam?
How you doin'?
- All right.
- Never forget about that,
'cause that's all we got.
(crowd chattering)
(cameras clicking)
Nice to meet you.
All right.
Oh, bring it in, bring it in!
(men laughing)
(President laughs)
Started from the
bottom, now we're here!
- Yeah!
- Nice to meet you.
All right, nice to meet you.
All right.
Nice to meet you.
- 1/8th black.
- Afternoon, my octa-roon,
come on, bring it
in there, tuck that.
- I'm in there, dog,
I'm in there, dog.
- You tuckin' it in there?
- I mean this.
- But you're tuck, though?
- Tuck, tuck.
- You tuckin'?
- I'm in there.
I'm in there.
- All right, nice
to meet you, man.
Oh, nice to meet you.
Oh, my goodness, look at this.
Oh, she is so beautiful.
(baby coos)
Mm, (lips smack) I
want another one.
There you go.
Precious, beautiful,
beautiful, what's her name?
- This is Livia Rougie.
- Okay, nice to meet
you, Miss Rougie.
All right.
Now, come on, there he is.
(hands smacking)
Boom! (laughs)
- Mr. President.
- All right, man,
good to meet you.
- [Liaison] Here we go,
right this way, sir.
(engine revving)
- Email is one-on-one, now,
that's the,
(car door clicks open)
man, you gotta have the
most space for attachments,
and, anyway,
- Thank you.
- Feel free to hit me up if
you remember that number,
I notice you ain't
write that down.
(car door slams shut)
(gearshift clicks)
Damn, damn, damn.
That girl was fly, right?
- She all right.
Psh, but did you see
that Liam Neesons movie
with them wolves, though?
- The one with them big ass
wolves and Liam Neesons in it?
- Man, Liam Neesons
is my (beep).
- Oh, Liam Neesons straight
jacked up them wolves, man.
- Man, yeah, he (beep)
them wolves up, man.
(valet attendant laughs)
Shoot, man, hey.
- Hoo!
- And don't even
get me started on that one
when they took his daughter.
- Psh, shh, straight "Tooken,"
starrin' Liam Neesons.
- Man, Liam Neeson's
on the phone, like,
"I have a certain
set of skills."
(valet attendant exclaims)
Man, don't (beep)
with Liam Neesons.
- Don't even try and be
Russian around Liam Neesons,
he'll take your arm, like,
(valet attendant crying out)
fractures 'em, like that.
(valet attendant
mimics arm breaking)
- Yeah, killin' 'em, man,
and then, oh, and you
see the second one, now?
In the second one, the
Russians come after him,
and he (beep) them
all up anyway.
- "Tooken 2," starrin' the
incomparable Liam Neesons.
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- That's my (beep).
- What about "Darkman," though?
- No.
- Huh?
What about Liam Neesons
in some "Darkman,"
- No.
- The (beep).
- What about "Darkman," though?
- When Liam Neeson's face
was changin' up there?
- Homie, homie was
straight face-changing.
Now, that's just Liam
Neeson's acting, right there.
- Look, straight
up, I kid you not,
Academy award caliber,
classic Neesons.
- Come on, seriously,
though, I mean, like,
Neesons already need
to have a statue.
- Liam Neesons ain't got none?
- He ain't got a statue.
He ain't got a statue.
- No, no, no.
The Oscar goes to Liam
Neesons, "Darkman,"
(beep) face was changin'.
- Mm-hmm, word.
- How hard is that?
- It ain't hard, dog.
It's not hard at all.
- Damn!
- It's stupid, man.
- Oh, psst, oh,
psst, "Battleship"?
(valet attendant yelling)
"Battleship."
(valet attendant
continues yelling)
"Battleship."
(valet attendant
continues yelling)
"Battleship!"
(valet attendant
continues yelling)
- Woo!
- Liam Neeson straight killed
a robot boat.
- Liam Neesons is my shiznit.
- Hoo!
- But, you know who I
like as much as Neesons?
- (blows raspberry)
As much as Neesons?
- Mm-hmm.
- Who?
- Bruce Willy.
(valet attendant yelling)
(feet tapping rhythmically)
- Bruce Willy is my (beep).
- But, what if they made a movie
with Liam Neesons
and Bruce Willy?
(valet attendant gasps)
- Neesons and Willy?
- Willy and Neesons.
- Harder, man, harder!
That would be (voice crackling),
- [Both] My jam!
(voices trailing loudly)
(explosion booms)
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh, I want ya ♪
♪ But I don't need ya ♪